[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Welcome
to Lecture 18 of 14.13.
This lecture's about gender
discrimination and identity.
OK.
So what's the agenda today?
Generally, we're going to
talk about gender, identity,
and particularly,
discrimination.
First, I'm going to give you
a broad and a quick overview
of why this is an
important area to study.
Then I'm going to give you
an equally brief overview
of the gender gap in wages,
the fact that women earn less
money than men for equal work,
how that has evolved over time,
and how much still is
left of this gender gap.
Then we're going to
talk for a little bit
about potential
technological solutions.
Can we use technology to improve
or to reduce discrimination
potentially?
And the answer would
be yes, to some extent.
But that technology will
not solve everything.
Then we're going to talk about
two particularly important
issues.
One is beliefs and
people's updating
about beliefs when it comes to
men and women and their skill.
And then we're going to talk
about gender identity norms
in particular, which is
the idea that people's
deeply held beliefs about
what should be done in society
or not might affect
their behavior.
And finally, we're going to
talk a little bit about demand
and supply for different tasks.
So in particular,
I'm going to show you
that women are more
likely to say yes
to what's called nonpromotable
tasks, tasks that
are good for
society, but perhaps
not good for their career,
or tasks that are good
for, like, a company or
a university as a whole,
but are not good, are not
promotable in the sense
that they help women,
in fact, get promoted.
Women are more likely to
say yes to those things.
In addition, on top of
that, precisely because they
are more likely to
say yes, they're
also more likely to be asked
in the first place, which sort
of amplifies that difference.
I'm going to tell you
about this in more detail.
The first question
you might ask is
why study gender differences?
I have four answers for you.
The first one is simple
equality, fairness,
and justice issues.
People simply should be rewarded
equally for the same output.
So if a man and a woman
works equally many hours
and is equally productive,
they should be paid the same.
And if that's not the
case, that's unequal.
That's unfair and not--
injust, or not justified.
Now there might be additional
equality and fairness issues
that men and women
might not even
be allowed to work
as much, women
might not be allowed
to work as much as men.
That's an additional
sort of fairness concern.
Second, there's an
efficiency argument,
which is overall
productivity and welfare
falls if women and other groups
are held back by discrimination
and other distortions.
And indeed, a substantial
share of recent US growth
can be explained by
improved allocation
of talent in the economy.
So this is just a
simple idea that, well,
if we exclude certain
groups, including women
from certain jobs, the most
talented people in those groups
will not be allowed to--
or some of the most talented
people in those groups
might not be allowed
to do those jobs.
And that's bad for
society overall.
Think about, for
example, doctors.
If women cannot be
doctors, well then,
we will essentially just exclude
a large fraction of the most
talented people in terms of
being doctors, the smartest,
brightest and hardest
working women.
And that will be worse
not just for those women,
but it will also be bad for
medical care, innovation,
and so on in the
medical profession
because you just essentially
exclude some of the best
people from that type of work.
And if you want to
learn more about this,
the paper by Hsieh et al.
is an excellent
discussion of this issue.
Third, we might learn
about the formation
of preferences in personality
by studying gender.
And here, the idea is that
there are, in many cases,
differences and preferences--
[INAUDIBLE] preferences,
social preferences--
and taste for competition
or competitiveness
but also attitudes
towards negotiation,
or other things such as
identity aspirations, or over-
or underconfidence
more generally.
Well, so if there are these
differences at later ages,
we can learn about the
formation of those preferences
in personality by looking,
for instance, at people
at different ages and trying
to understand at which ages
those differences emerge.
For instance, you might
look at 5-year-olds
or 10-year-olds or
15-year-olds and look
at their risks and
social preferences,
and then try to understand
when those gender gaps emerge
over time.
And that will allow us, then, to
understand questions of nature
versus nurture,
whether there are
inherent differences in
preferences and personality
overall, just men and women
are just different inherently
for some reason.
Or it could be that it's
really about socialization
and education and the like.
Girls and boys are just
treated very differently
by their parents, by
their social environments,
their teachers,
and so on, and that
might create such
differences and preferences
and other behaviors.
So that's another
reason to study those.
You're going to mostly focus
on number one, just simply
the idea, the objective that
people should be rewarded
equally for the same help.
Now what is the gender gap?
What do I mean when I
talk about the gender gap?
So Claudia Goldin, who is a
eminent researcher at Harvard,
who has done a lot of
seminal work on gender
and the economics of gender,
has written a very nice overview
paper in 2014 and giving an
overview of what do we know
and how far have we come in
trying to reduce and close
the gender gap.
The graph that I'm showing
here summarizes this discussion
fairly well.
It's a bit of a messy graph.
So let me show
you what it shows,
or tell you what it shows.
On the x-axis, you see
people's age from 20 to 70.
On the y-axis, you see the log
of female to male earnings,
or average female
to male earnings.
Which is essentially a
measure of the gender gap,
and so the difference
in log is essentially
the percentage difference in
female versus male earnings.
So minus 0.3, and we think of
that as, like, 30% difference
in female versus male earnings.
What do we see here?
Well, A, we see a
pretty large gender gap
anywhere in this graph.
I should have also said
different lines are now
different cohorts.
So these are starting in 1923,
so people born in 1923, '28,
'33, '38, '43, and so on,
at five year intervals,
from the oldest to like
more recent cohorts.
Now what do we see?
We see a significant gender
gap everywhere in this graph,
or in all lines of the graph.
We see that the gender gap,
even for the most recent cohort
seems to be about 20% to 30%.
We see that the
gender gap has fallen.
So when you look
at like the most--
the oldest cohorts,
the gender gap
was even larger than
the more recent cohorts.
You also see that there's
sort of this U-shape, where
we seem to find that the gender
gap starts emerging already
at age 27, 28, 30.
There's already a gender gap
of something like 10% to 15%,
even for the most
recent cohorts.
But then that gender gap
gets magnified towards, like,
[INAUDIBLE] 20% 30%, 40%,
until about age 40 to 45,
when it's at a plateau.
So maybe it falls a bit overall.
So what do we learn here?
Well, there are substantial
female labor market
gains in the last half century.
But large gender gaps remain.
In 2010, for instance, the
ratio of mean annual earnings
between male and
female workers, these
are people who worked full-time,
full year, 25 to 69 years,
was 0.72, and that of
the median was 0.77.
Notice that the
figure here controls
for work time and education.
So while of course, it
might also be the case,
it is indeed the case that
women work fewer hours in a day
than men do, even conditional
on work time education,
there's a significant
gap, gender gap
remaining of something
like 20 to 30%
that women are paid
less for equal work.
Now first, what are
some of the reasons why
there have been substantial
female labor market gains
over the last half century?
Well, there's quite
a few technological
and other explanatory factors.
One big factor was a reduction
in the gender gap in education.
Women are just more able and
can afford to receive education.
That's true for both primary,
secondary education, but also,
in particular, for university
or higher education,
more generally.
Second, there's been
technological innovations,
such as the pill,
dishwasher, and so on,
which allowed women to do more
work outside of the household.
There have also been
labor demand shifts.
In particular,
the US economy has
been moving from
manufacturing and agriculture
towards services.
Women tend to have
comparative advantages
in services compared to like,
in particular, hard manual.
And so these labor demand shifts
then have disproportionately
benefited women.
Finally, there's been
also lower discrimination,
in particular, stronger
regulatory controls
and increased market
competitiveness.
For the latter, it's if
there's more competition,
firms cannot afford to
discriminate as much.
Because it's actually
a costly thing
to do, to hire incompetent men
compared to competent women.
Now we're going to discuss
a paper by Goldin and Rouse,
which is an example of a
simple technological solution,
in particular, this question
whether blind auditions
in orchestras increased gender
ratios in those orchestras.
So is the fact that people--
the blind auditions
were introduced,
did that contribute to
the increase in the gender
ratio in orchestras?
What do I mean by the
increase in gender ratios
in the orchestras?
So even until the
1960s, '70s, and '80s,
there were shockingly low
female ratios in top orchestras
and orchestras more generally.
Now these ratios were below
10% in many orchestras.
And only recently,
in the '80s and '90s,
in particular, there
were stark increases
in the number of women who
play in those orchestras.
This increase was the case
in the top five orchestras,
but [INAUDIBLE] also has been,
have been similar improvements
in gender ratios in
other orchestras,
which you can read in the report
that I linked in the slides.
Now one really
important reason here
seems to have been blatant
sexism, even by very renowned,
or in particular, by renowned
conductors, which you can--
I'm not going to
repeat here, but you
can read it in section one of
the paper by Goldin and Rouse.
And so one question
is like, well,
is there's this sexism
and discrimination,
has that contributed to the
low gender ratio in orchestras?
Now while there have been
all these improvements
in the gender ratio [INAUDIBLE]
musicians in general?
There still are vast
differences in conductors
and the number of conductors
and music directors.
They're essentially
predominantly male still.
Moreover, while there have
been a lot of improvements
in terms of gender, most
musicians are still white.
So in particular,
African-Americans and Latinos
are very much underrepresented
in orchestras.
Now let me tell you a short
aside about women in economics.
This is not just the
case that in orchestras
the fraction of women is low,
that's also true in economics.
And here's an overview of that.
There's a [INAUDIBLE] paper by
Lundberg and Stearns in 2019,
which essentially says that
some progress has been made,
but lots more needs to be done.
And more recently,
in particular,
some of the progress
seems to have stalled.
What do we mean by that?
Well, here this graph
shows the fraction
of women in different stages
of the profession ranging
from senior mangers here at the
top to first-year PhD students
to assistant professors,
new assistant professors,
associate professors,
and full professors.
And what you see
here, there seems
to be some trend that's
upwards, in particular
for full professors and
associate professors,
which is, of course, good.
there's less of a positive
trend to be seen in particular
when it comes to
assistant professors.
Here you essentially
see since 2000--
about 2007 or 2006 has been
no increase, if anything,
like a decrease in the fraction
of female assistant professors.
But even the fraction of PhD
students is clearly below 50%.
And so the profession
is starting
to understand and
address the issues,
in particular, to
try to reduce sexism,
and other issues
holding women back.
For example, some
particularly nice examples
of these mentoring
programs, which
are trying to support female and
minority assistant professors
and in terms of mentoring
and trying to sort of
foster their careers, which
has been shown to impact
and significantly
improve the profession.
For what it's worth in '14,
'13, the majority of students
tends to be female.
And moreover, the best students
tend to be female as well.
So very much hope you
are still interested
and all the female
students are very much
still interested in economics
and would pursue a career
in economics, perhaps academic.
Now back to orchestra,
so many orchestras
introduced blind auditions
in the 1970s and 1980s.
And if you look back at the
graph that I showed you--
this graph here-- you see in the
1970s, '80s, and '90s, that's
also the time when there was
a sharp increase in the share
of women in those orchestras.
So you can see
here in the graphs,
orchestras, if you want to
get a job in orchestras,
you have to do auditions.
These auditions are
very, very competitive
and often have like
several stages.
There are preliminary,
semifinals, and final symphony
orchestras.
What you see here is 11
anonymized orchestras,
including the top
orchestras in the US,
and the introduction of blind
auditions in those orchestras.
What you see is
that most orchestras
did introduce blind
auditions at least in some
of their stages
of the auditions.
However, many of them also only
introduce it in some stages,
but not in others.
Now you can think already
that that's not sufficient.
In some cases, if you have
only like blind auditions
in the preliminaries, but not
in the semifinals and finals,
you might sort of
reduce discretization
in the preliminaries.
But then if women are
discriminated in the semifinals
or finals, that's not going to
help them get hired, which is,
at the end of the day,
we, of course, care about.
Now Goldin and Rouse look
at technological solutions
and look at the question of
whether such technological
solutions, in fact, can help.
Now the question to
ask now is looking
at data from actual auditions,
often using individual fixed
effects, do these blind
auditions, the introduction
of blind auditions help
candidates reach the next round
or, in particular, get hired.
Now the data is fairly
rich and often includes
or allows for the inclusion
of individual fixed effects.
That is the case if you
look at the musicians,
Goldin and Rouse are
going to ask the question,
is a particular
musician more likely
to make it to the next round
when auditions are blinded?
And is that more likely
the case for female
than for male musicians?
Now what did they find overall?
They find evidence that
blind audition procedures
fostered impartiality
in hiring and increased
the proportion of women
in symphony orchestras.
Now there's some caveats
here that, you know,
some of these estimates
are fairly imprecise,
in particular, in
the later stages
because a number of observations
was down quite a bit.
Some of these results
are a little bit mixed.
But overall, the
evidence suggests
that these blind
auditions did indeed
foster impartiality and help
women succeed in getting jobs,
in particular in these top
orchestras in the West.
Now why are these
results perhaps somewhat
less clear cut?
I already told you
like one reason is
that in the later rounds,
the number of observations
gets kind of small because no
longer have so many people make
it to the later rounds.
But there's another
reason, which
is the auditions have several
rounds, not all of which
were blinded.
Now if there's one--
if there's discrimination
in one round,
but not in the next one, this
issue that in the next round,
there will be like
selection, and in particular,
the discriminated people who
make it to the next round,
you expect them to
do better, right?
If there's discrimination
against women
in the first round,
but not in a second,
you think that women
in the second round
will do better because only
the best women will make it
to the second round
because otherwise they
will be screened out
in the first round
due to discrimination.
But if that's the case,
then making comparisons
in later rounds is potentially
biased or problematic
because you're comparing
essentially different types
of people in different rounds.
And that leads to the results
being less clear-cut overall.
Let me give you another example.
Suppose male and female workers
get graded on their task ,
a coding task, online where you
essentially see their output,
but you also see their gender.
Now suppose women get
graded systematically
worse due to sexism
and no other reasons.
Suppose women and men
are exactly the same
in the work they do,
but some men are sexist
and they're going
to rate women worse.
Now for any given score,
you should expect the women
that you hire compared to any
other random man that you hire
to do better than that man.
And the reason being that
they have been systematically
disadvantaged due to the sexism
in the rating to start with.
Now you should think about this.
Because, you know,
there's also some evidence
of teaching evaluations
being biased against women.
Now if you see a man and a woman
are at the exact same teaching
rating, well, you would probably
want to take the woman's class
because the woman has been--
the female professor has been
discriminated to start with.
Having that high score or
the similarly high score
as the male professor is
more impressive and likely
to indicate that the
class will be better.
There's an excellent
paper by Bohren et. al.
that considers the issue of--
the dynamics of discrimination
in much more detail if you're
interested in learning more
about that.
Now despite the
technological solution
that advances that image,
[INAUDIBLE] substantial gender
gaps remain.
So while, as I told
you, the gender gap
has been reduced both in terms
of labor market or labor force
participation, how many days and
hours, how many women overall,
how many days and
hours those women work
and in their wages and earnings,
how much they are being paid
conditional on working,
there are still
substantial gender gaps.
In particular, women's
labor market participation
has plateaued since
the early 1990s.
And even now, among
entering cohorts,
women still earn
significantly less than men.
And that's true
even for conditional
on work time and education.
That's the graph that I
was showing you earlier.
Now given that there are these
persistent remaining gender
gaps even though a lot of
the technological and other
barriers have been reduced--
now women are educated
or as educated as men are and
there's less technological
barriers that preclude
women from working,
researchers have now started
to consider some of less
traditional within
economic factors,
including things such as risk
attitudes, negotiation skills,
taste for computation,
but also--
and this is what we're
going to focus on--
beliefs and social
norms and identity.
I'm going to first
talk about beliefs
and then we're going to
talk about social norms
and identity.
Before we get to
beliefs about gender,
people's-- women's
and men's skills,
I'm going to tell you very
briefly about a seminal paper
by Bertrand and Mullainathan
from 2004 that randomizes--
randomized names in
job applications.
So what they're trying to do--
they essentially sent
out job applications
that were otherwise identical,
male and female workers.
These are fictitious
job applications.
And they sent them to
employers and then looked
at callback rates
by those employers.
And the only thing that was like
varied in those applications
was the name on the application.
And what did they do?
Well, they used white-sounding
names such as Emily and Greg,
as well as African-American
sounding names
such as Lakisha and Jamal.
And then they looked at,
well, were these applications,
when they had
white-sounding names that
were otherwise identical, more
successful than applications
by names with
African-American-sounding names
and, again, that were
otherwise identical?
And Bertrand and Mullainathan
find a striking result
that callback rates for
white-sounding names
were 50% higher than for
African-American-sounding
names.
That's a huge difference.
And that's important
not just because it's
a hassle because you have to
send out more applications,
but if you get called
back more, you're
more likely to be interviewed
or asked for an interview,
you're more likely to
actually get the job,
you're more likely to--
less likely to be unemployed,
and you might also
be less likely to stop searching
whatsoever because you might
be disappointed or discouraged.
So that's a huge difference
and, essentially, discrimination
against African-Americans
was blatantly obvious
from this research.
Numerous other studies show
gender and racial biases
in various ways.
These are ranging from very
similar studies, including
these audit studies where people
are sent resumes and the like,
but also ranging to studies
where like people on eBay
tried to sell things,
where they try
to sell like an iPad
or iPhone, and they
hold that iPhone with
hands that's either
like white or non-white.
And then they find
essentially that white hands
are more likely to sell their
iPhones than non-white hands.
Now this is a very important
and depressing result.
One thing to flag here that it's
hard to distinguish statistical
from case-based discrimination.
You're going to talk more
about this recitation.
What do I mean by that?
Well, it might be
that there is--
people have a preference
for white applicants.
That is to say, controlling
for performance,
it might just be that
people are racist
and they'd rather
have white applicants
than African-American
applicants.
This is what economists would
call case-based discrimination,
which essentially is
conditional on the performance.
People just like certain types
of people better than others.
And, therefore, they
call them or are
more likely to call them back.
A different explanation is
belief-based explanation.
It might be that
employers think that
African-American applicants
will perform worse,
even controlling for all
other aspects of the resume.
So it could be essentially
you see, people see this name
and they think that even
if the resume is good,
that person will not perform
work as well as somebody
with a white-sounding name.
Notice that these beliefs
could be correct or not,
but in any case, we will-- and
that's-- we'll talk about this
in recitation as well.
Economists again, would
call this statistical
discrimination.
This could be, again, correct
statistical estimation
or statistical discrimination
that's based on biased beliefs.
But either way,
these things jointly
led to clear discrimination of
African-American applications,
which, in turn, leads
to striking differences
in unemployment or job
finding rates across races.
We're going to now focus on
beliefs and, in particular,
about beliefs about
skills and how
people update on those
beliefs depending
on the gender of the
person they're updating on.
The people we are
going to consider now
is the paper by
Sarsons, 2019, which
considers how people interpret
signals in the labor market.
The question that
Sarsons asks here
is whether somebody's
gender influences
the way we interpret
information about this person
and about his or her peers.
What do I mean by that?
Well, in many situations
when people do certain tasks
and perform at work, good
things and bad things happen.
Now you can infer from
these things that occur,
from these events, you
can infer something
about their competence
and their performance.
While many of these situations
are ambiguous in the sense
it could be that the person was
just really lucky or it could
be that the person is
really, really good
at what they're doing.
Now what Sarsons is asking
when we see those events
and when people
see those events,
are people interpreting
those events differently
for men versus women?
So, for example, if a man-- if
something bad happens at work,
a boss might react
to that person
differently or
update their beliefs
about the person's skills
differently depending
whether it's man or woman.
In addition, the boss might
also update differently
about the peers.
So if a woman makes
a mistake, the boss
might not only
update his beliefs
about this woman, but also
about all other women that
work for him.
Similarly, for a man, of course,
the boss might do the same.
And what Heather Sarsons
now asks is the question,
is this updating or the
interpretation of information
differently for male
versus female workers?
And why do we care?
Well, we care a lot about this
because hiring, promotion,
and wage decisions
hinge on information
about workers' ability.
And in particular, if
there's systematic difference
in how information about men
and women is interpreted,
that could lead to differences
in hiring, promotion, and wage
decisions and, in turn, might
contribute to the gender gap.
What does Sarsons do to
answer this question?
She looks at how do
physicians change referrals
to surgeons and their
peers after a patient,
after certain patient outcomes?
Now what I mean by
that, physicians often
refer patients needing
surgery to a local surgeon.
So somebody breaks
their arm or their leg,
well, many physicians
can't do this on their own,
so they will refer this
patient to a local surgeon.
Now the referral choice
reflects the physician's beliefs
about the surgeon's
ability, right?
You want to do the
best for your patient.
And you want to
send that patient
to the best possible surgeon.
So if you have a
suspicion, if you
think a certain surgeon
is not competent,
you better not send your
patient to that surgeon,
in part, because you might
care a lot about the patient,
in part, because,
you know, if you
make bad referrals, that might
also reflect on you eventually.
Now what does Sarsons
do specifically?
To document whether
the reaction depends
on the surgeon's gender.
What does Sarsons do?
She matches on surgeon and
patient characteristics
on procedures.
That is to say, she takes male
and female surgeons and patient
characteristics and procedures--
which is like, you know,
broken arms versus more
complicated procedures--
so she matches all of those
characteristics and such
that in observations set,
she has surgeons only
differ by gender.
And then she considers what
we call an event study, which
is comparing how
physicians reacts
to male and female surgeons
when good and bad things happen.
Let me now show you more
precisely what we mean.
So we have here on
the x-axis, quarters.
On the y-axis, we have the
referrals from the physicians
to the performing surgeon.
So these are essentially
dyads or pairs of physicians
and performing surgeons.
And you see here minus
1 is normalized to be 0.
And then, essentially, you see
the evolution of the referrals
from a specific physician
to a performing surgery.
These are men and women.
And these are essentially
cases in which
there is no adverse event
or the adverse events
are like a patient's
death, for example.
What you see are
essentially these are
men and women that are matched.
They're supposed to
look exactly the same.
And what we see here is that
referrals increase over time.
They tend to sort of increase
fairly steeply over time
and then sort of
plateau off over time.
The exact shape and pattern
of this relationship
doesn't matter so much.
However, what matters
is that men and women
look exactly the same, right?
So the performing
surgeon is here.
The gender here that
varies is the gender
of the performing surgery.
Now then she looks at--
Sarsons looks at cases in which
there is an adverse event.
Again, the adverse event
happens around here.
So what you see here is then
when there is an adverse event,
there's a clear
punishment in the sense
of like the male
surgeon now gets
fewer referrals from
the physician right
after the adverse event happens.
So this is manifested
by the blue bars
being lower than the gray bars.
Notice that the number
doesn't go down.
It's still above-- everything
here is above the red line.
So it's just the
physician is not
increasing the referrals
over time anymore
or that increase gets
dampened by the adverse event.
This is for the male surgeon.
Let's look at now what
happens to the female surgeon.
What we see here is a clearer
difference that opens up
after the adverse event.
Notice that there's
no pre-trends here.
Before, it looks--
men and women,
or female and male
surgeons, including
the red and the blue bars
look exactly the same.
But the bar, the
difference only opens up
after the adverse event.
And there's a pretty
large gap, you can see,
that shows up in the referrals.
And this gap is way
larger if you compare
the red versus the gray lines--
it's way larger
compared to the gap
with the divergence between
the blue and the gray lines.
So what we see here is
that both men and women
are punished in the sense
of receiving fewer referrals
after an adverse event.
That punishment is way
more severe for female
than for male surgeons.
Now let's do the same for
the absence of a good event
aren't actually good
events that happen.
What's a good event?
Well, it's essentially a
surprisingly good thing
that happened where
there's a complicated
surgery and the person
does really well.
What we see here is, again,
sort of the men and women,
they look pretty much
exactly the same.
You can see here maybe men are
doing slightly better overall.
But overall, these gray lines
look very similar over time.
Now, if there's a good
event that happens,
you see, essentially, men
get very much rewarded.
If the male surgeon
does well, he
gets rewarded in the sense of
receiving a lot more referrals
from the PCP, from the doctor.
Now if you do the same
for female surgeon.
Again, female surgeons
benefit from that.
But the increase in referrals
is a lot lower than for men.
So, again, both men
and women, there
is a reaction to
that information,
to a good or a bad event.
But the reaction tends to
be much stronger, much more
favorable for men.
In terms of the good events,
men get rewarded more
for the good events.
And women get punished more
for bad events, [INAUDIBLE]
bad events that happen.
Let me summarize
the main results.
After a bad outcome, after, for
example like a patient death,
there is a 34 decrease in
referrals to female surgeon--
surgeons.
And there's a stagnation in
referrals to male surgeons.
So, essentially, women tend
to be punished quite a lot.
Men, a little bit in
the sense that referrals
don't go up anymore, but
the punishment is much less.
Now, strikingly,
physicians are also
less likely to refer to
other female surgeons.
That is to say, if
a female surgeon,
if a patient dies
from a female surgeon,
the physician is also
less likely to refer
patients, future patients
to other female surgeons.
These other female surgeons,
nobody has died there.
So, essentially,
what seems to be
the case is that the physicians
also are updating about women
or female surgeons in general if
there is a negative event that
happens, which is
sort of very striking.
After a good outcome, such
as unanticipated survival,
there's a doubling of
referrals to male surgeons
but only a 70% increase in
referrals to female surgeons.
And there are here--
there's no spillovers
to other female surgeons.
So, again, what do we find here?
Well, we find that
women are punished more
for unexpected bad events.
And they're rewarded less
for unexpected good events.
That is to say, it's
not just the case
that there's more updating
going on, in the sense
maybe you learn more
from good and bad events
because maybe you have like less
information about men and women
to start with.
That's not the case here.
What is here the case
is that there's more
updating or more punishment
for mistakes for women and less
reward for good
things to happen,
for good events
for women as well.
Now, why do these
asymmetries matter?
Well, one important issue here
is that women have more chances
to make mistakes.
And, in particular, if
there is like dropping out,
if women don't get promoted
or if they even drop out,
that leads to lower
skill accumulation
and, you know, women will
be just less qualified
overall in the end because
they have less chances
to get promoted and
get more responsibility
and so on and so forth and
then they even drop out overall
and we just have fewer
women in the profession.
Now, moreover,
usually wage gaps are
measured conditional skills,
industry, and position.
But if there is
biased evaluations
that then lead to differences
in skills and positions
in the workplace, not
only is it the case
that women are receiving wage
gaps conditional on the skills,
but they also have different
skills and positions
in the workplace because
of biased evaluations.
So that's an additional
scope for discrimination
and differences in
earnings and so on.
And then, importantly,
this is also
not a mistake that can
get corrected over time.
Because if women drop
out in particular, then--
or if there's no referrals
that happen anymore,
then the doctor or
any other person
might not receive any
signals anymore from work.
If you sort of update
on a particular person
that that patient of mine
died because I sent them
to that person,
if you then think,
you know, this
person is terrible
and don't send any
further patients anymore,
you will never learn that
this woman was, in fact, very
much highly qualified
and that was just
an accident that could
have happened to anyone.
So that's a really
important issue that--
so when women are
underrepresented
employers see fewer
outcomes overall,
and if there is updates
more of the bad outcomes,
or, in particular, if there's
also updates about all women,
then there will be fewer chances
to learn and then women are let
go and so on or less
likely to be hired,
then there will be no chance
of actually correcting
those [INAUDIBLE].
Strikingly, as I told you,
what's really important
as a result is that seems
to be like updating,
not just about
one specific woman
overall after the
negative events,
but also about all other
women that get punished
for the bad event that happens.
And if that's the
case, if there's
several women in the
profession, then all women
always have to pay for
any bad events that
happen to any woman.
And sometimes, you know,
mistakes, in fact, happen.
That's, of course, terrible
because that sort of amplifies
a lot of the updating.
Because even if somebody
makes no mistakes whatsoever,
negative updates happen
on their performance,
other women perform
negatively in some ways.
Now one question you
might ask is, well,
couldn't we just use algorithms,
machine learning, et cetera,
to overcome such biases?
In particular, instead
of hiring and so on,
couldn't you use
algorithms and machine
learning to train those
algorithms and instead
of use computers instead of
humans and then, you know,
we might get rid
of those biases?
Well, one key
problem with that is
that algorithms
themselves can be biased.
Now why is that?
Well, we train algorithms
based on human decisions.
As an example, if you
train an algorithm--
this is, in fact, what
some companies did,
based on actual
decisions, you get
asked the question, this
[INAUDIBLE],, if you train
that as an actual hiring
decisions or interview
decisions or you say, well,
would this person be invited
or is this person, is this
resume likely to be invited
for an interview?
Well, if those interviewing
decisions to start with
were biased based
on sexism, racism,
and so on, if you train
your algorithm on it, then
very much you make that
algorithm biased as well.
Now, crucially, that's,
of course, problematic
and I very much would
like to avoid that.
And we want to be very careful.
But, crucially,
some of these biases
can be perhaps easier
or fixed and perhaps
fixed more easily than biases
in human decision-making, right?
If somebody is sexist
or racist, it's
very hard to fix this, at
least in the short run.
However, an algorithm,
essentially,
is just doing whatever
you train them to do.
So if you build equity concerns
into the objective function
of an algorithm, then
we can essentially
reduce or even eliminate
these biases explicitly
because the algorithm is
explicitly asked to do so.
And so there's a
fascinating-- if you
want to learn more
about this overall,
there's a fascinating
talk on discrimination
by algorithms and people
by Sendhil Mullainathan
that I've linked
here in the slides
that you can watch it
and learn more about.
But overall, so just
to say, to summarize,
algorithms can be biased,
but they can also be fixed.
And that's an important
research agenda
that people have been
working on more recently,
the design of fair algorithms.
Next, we're going to talk
about gender identity
norms and a very nice paper
by Bertrand et. al. from 2015.
Identity considerations were
imported from social psychology
to economics in multiple
papers by Akerlof and Kranton
in particular in 2000.
There's a very nice book
about identity economics
if you're interested in
learning more about that.
Gender identity norms
are an important example
or application of such norms
or identity considerations
more generally.
In particular, Akerlof and
Kranton, or we here as well,
focus on two social
categories, men and women.
For simplicity, we can also just
talk about husbands and wives,
understanding things are
more complicated in reality.
But for simplicity, we're
going to focus on that for now.
What do we mean by
gender identity?
Well, gender
identity is something
that changes payoffs from
different action as dictated
by some prescriptive norms.
What might those norms be?
Well, one norm would
be men should not
do women's work in the
house, in the home,
like cooking,
cleaning, and so on.
Some men might consider
that as women's work.
And they might feel
particularly high disutility
from doing so if they
violate that law.
Another norm would be men should
earn more than their wives.
Now husbands now lose identity,
experience lower utility
in circumstances when these
prescriptions are violated,
when he does housework, or when
his wife earns more than half
of the household income.
Notice that wives might
also lose identity.
For simplicity, we're
going to talk more--
only about husbands,
I'm doing so for now.
Now Bertrand et. al.
particularly focus
on the prescription
that men should earn
more than their wives.
And it's important to notice
that this particular gender
identity norm would only matter
in a world where women could--
would not matter
in a world where
women could never earn more
than her actual or potential
husband.
But if women are held back
by technological factors,
by education, et cetera,
and never even earn
close to as much as their
husbands or potential husbands,
well, then the gender identity
norm is kind of irrelevant.
However, as women make
gains in the labor market,
these slow moving
gender identity norms
can become increasingly relevant
and increasingly relevant
constraints.
So now as women have more
and more earnings potential
and are much--
be quite likely to earn
more than their husbands,
these norms really bite
and might hold women back.
Now how would you study
this question empirically?
The idea here in Bertrand et.
al. is that, well,
if husbands loose
identity when their wives earn
more than half the household
income, well, then
they will try to avoid
such situations, either--
in various ways,
and particularly
by avoiding such marriages
in the first place.
But also if those
marriages happen,
that might lead to
divorce and so on
and those marriages
might break up.
So the idea of a
paper then is to look
for a missing mass in couples
where, particularly in
places where the husband
earns just a little bit more
than their wife.
Now how do they do that?
Well, they have to look at the
distribution of relative income
using US admin data.
What do I mean by
relative income?
Relative income is the
income between the husband
and the wife.
They have essentially,
there's a very nice survey,
data of the survey income
and program participation.
These are a series of
representative national panels
that about 70,000 couple
observations from 1992 to 2004.
This includes couples only
in which both the husbands
and wives are earning
positive income.
So notice that this was
not about husband and wife
working at all.
It's not about women being
at home versus working.
But it's about cases where
both couples or both spouses
have positive income.
Their income measure is
annual total labor income
plus self-employed
income as well.
Now using that data,
Bertrand et. al.
can now compute the
shares of couples
earning different
fractions of total income.
So what I'm going to
show you is the fraction
of the wife as a share of
total income in the household.
And that's graphed
using 20 bits.
What does this graph look like?
You can see here the
share earned by the wife
is just a fraction of couples.
This overall.
So this is all the couples.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
This all adds up
to 100% overall.
And what you see is, perhaps not
surprisingly, that the share--
the fraction of couple for which
the share of earned by the wife
is higher than 50%
is not super high.
That's not surprising
given that men on average
are earning more than women.
So that's not the question here.
The question here is, is there
a missing mass just above 50%?
The idea is, suppose there are
some couples where women earn
45% or 46% or even 49%,
there the norm does not
cause an issue or there's
no identity problems
because the husband
earns somewhat more
and feels happy about it.
But as soon as you cross
the threshold to like 51%,
now there's a problem.
Now the woman earns more.
The husband feels uncomfortable,
unhappy and so on.
And that might lead to
those marriages disappearing
in various ways.
A, they might not form
in the first place.
Potential husband
and wife might never
even marry because husband
gets uncomfortable or does not
want to marry somebody
who earns more.
Second, there might be divorces.
These marriages
might essentially
dissolve because there's lots
of conflict in the household.
Now, how does that
manifest here?
You can look at
like if you come--
if you look at the graph and
look at this line here coming
from the left was 50%, you
can kind of look at like,
try to predict-- and it's kind
of the idea of the empirical
strategy--
you can try to predict what
fraction would you expect
there to be just above 50%?
And when you do that,
you think, you know,
the fraction should be
about something like 7%,
should be about here.
But, instead, there's this
jump down to about 6%.
So there's about 1% of
couples are missing here.
There's a missing
mass going on here,
which suggests that there
are some marriages that
are do not happen or dissolve
because of those identity
concerns.
This is what I
already said here.
There's a cliff to
the right of 0.5
in the distribution of relative
earnings in most couples.
And that's an implication
of the prescription
that men should earn
more than their wives.
Now what are the mechanisms
behind this missing mass?
Bertrand et. al. had a wealth
of evidence, additional evidence
showing these mechanisms.
In particular, they
show three mechanisms,
which is, first,
missing couples did not
form in the first place.
When you look at--
when you just randomly match
men and women, some of which
were men have higher earnings
potential compared to women
and the other way
around, the couples
where women are earning just
somewhat less than women
are just much less
likely or less
likely to marry
compared to couples
where women are just earning
somewhat less than men.
Second, such couples are less
happy and stable and more
likely to end in divorce.
So conditional on
marrying, they're
more likely to get divorced as
marriages just end unhappily.
And that's, of course,
then also contributes
to this missing mass.
And then third, in cases where
wives have higher earnings
potential than
their husbands, they
decide now to work less outside
of the household or, you know,
put in less [INAUDIBLE] work so
they get less promoted, which
then sort of pushes
down their earnings
or increased husband's
earnings in relative terms,
such as done in such cases
the woman earns less than 50%.
And that also leads
to that missing mass.
In fact, what you see
here is this increase
in mass going from
like 20% to 40%,
which perhaps is
also like the reason
because some of the
mass that's missing here
is pushed here to the left.
Now, in addition to working
less outside of the household
and just working fewer hours and
working less overtime, it's on,
women then are also held
back by non-marketing
in childcare work.
So women, in
particular, women who
are earning just a little
bit more than their husbands
are doing more nonmarket and
childcare work, which is often
called the second shift.
So the idea here
is that husbands
even when his identity gets
threatened by the woman earning
more than he does,
and then he can
particularly not to the
childcare or nonmarket work.
So the woman ends up not
only working more outside
of the household and earning
more and being more productive
in that work, but also
doing more work at home
and in addition to that.
That's essentially what's called
the second or double shift.
Now an additional issue that is
a really important contributor
to the gender gap is
the arrival of children.
And this is a very nice
paper by Kleven et. al. that
looks at people's
earning, in particular,
the earning, how earnings
devolve after the birth
of a couple's first child.
This is an event study
that looks at years
over time for men and women.
And what you see essentially
for men, these are earnings
and on the right here
you have hours worked.
For men, essentially,
there's barely
any difference, if any
difference, of earnings
once the first child is born.
Essentially, men's earnings
tend to be pretty flat.
In contrast, of
course, that could be
for the growth that's avoided.
But, you know, at least
there's no reduction
in men's [INAUDIBLE].
This is, by the
way, Danish data.
Now for women, however,
there's a clearer reduction
in earnings.
And the long-run child
penalty is about almost 20%.
So, essentially, women after--
if you look at
men and women that
earn the same to start
with, women earn about 20%
less in the long run.
That is due to the
first child or after--
this gap arises after
the first child was born.
This is true for earnings.
It's also true for hours worked.
And there the
penalty is about 10%.
It's also true for
wages, as in how much
are people paid
conditional on work.
So part of that is
women working less.
But part of it is also women
earning less, a la being
promoted less, being paid less,
getting fewer raises and so on
once the child is born.
One very interesting
fact in this paper
is that child penalties are
transmitted through generations
from parents to
daughters, suggesting
an influence of child
environment on gender identity.
There seems to be something
about the gender identity
about the woman is supposed
to take care of the child
and that runs in the family.
And that leads to
particularly large
what they call child penalties
for those kinds of women
compared to men.
Now one thing you
might say is, well,
couldn't we have some gender
neutral family policies
that alleviate that?
And, in particular, in
academia, for instance, one idea
is one could use gender neutral
tenure clock stopping policies
to alleviate such issues.
And the idea is
that, in particular,
sort of early
years of the career
are particularly valuable.
So the very least
we can do is we
can stop the tenure clocks
to help women or couples
to deal with childcare.
And many, many universities and
research intensive universities
in the US have
adopted such what's
called gender neutral tenure
clock policies in the US.
Now what do I mean
by gender neutral?
Essentially, if a couple has a
child, not only does the woman,
if she has given
birth to the child,
does she get an extension
in the tenure clock,
but also the spouse will get
such an extension as well.
So it's gender
neutral in that sense.
Now, what would such
policies then do?
Well, they're intended to
involve men more in child care
and foster that, the idea
being like if you only
give that extension to
women, it sort of pushes
women to take care
of their children
and sort of not to work.
And perhaps if we involve
both spouses or parents
in the childcare, providing
those gender neutral
tenure clock stopping policies
might contribute to that.
But, of course,
there's no enforcement
and thus, potentially,
such policies
in that potentially
these policies
might be even enhancing
gender inequality.
And, particularly,
if it's the case
that if men take advantage
of this tenure clock
stopping policy by essentially
just having another year to do
research, but still don't
do very much in supporting
the child, then men might
actually benefit from it,
while women might not
benefit at all in part
because, relatively,
they're going
to do worse compared to men.
And so Antecol look, in fact,
at the impact of these adoptions
of these supposedly gender
neutral tenure clock
stopping policies.
And they find that
the introduction
of this policy at [INAUDIBLE]
economics department
substantially reduced female
tenure rates while increasing
male tenure rates.
So essentially what looks like
a neutral policy, in fact,
is not gender neutral at all.
It makes things worse for
women and better for men.
Let me tell you about
one final paper on gender
identity and the labor market.
This paper is called "'Acting
wife'-- marriage market
incentives and labor
market investments."
It's by Bursztyn et. al.
and it asks the question
whether women avoid
career-enhancing actions
because these actions signal
undesirable or seemingly
undesirable traits such as
ambition to the marriage
market.
There's two parts in the paper.
One part is just
observational data
that finds that while married
and unmarried female MBA
students perform similarly
when their performance is
unobserved by classmates, such
on some exams or problem sets,
unmarried women have lower
participation grades which are
observed by their classmates.
And so the idea here is that
only unmarried female MBA
students have incentives
on the marriage market.
And, therefore, when their
participation is observed,
when their performance
is observed,
they might want to scale
back their ambition
because they look too ambitious
on the marriage market.
And that might be adversely
interpreted by potential dates.
And, of course, married women,
since they are already married,
don't have that incentive.
So they don't engage
in such behavior.
As you might know, there's
lots of dating going on.
So lots of MBA students are
actively looking for a spouse
during their experience,
both men and women.
Now in addition, they have
field experiments with MBAs
in which they vary the
expectation whether responses
in a real stake
placement questionnaire
is going to be made public, in
particular, whether it's going
to be observed by their peers.
And now female,
single female students
reported or desired
salary and willingness
to travel and work long hours
on those questionnaires when
they expected their classmates
to see their preferences.
That is to say, when these
questions are public,
single female students reported
lower ambition as manifested
by desired salaries and
willingness to travel and work
hours, presumably
because they want
to look more favorable
on the marriage market.
Notably, other groups'
responses were affected
by such peer observability.
So in other groups, it
didn't matter whether it's
in public and in private.
In addition, there's
a second experiment
that indicates the effects were
driven by the observability
by a single male peers.
That is to say, if another
woman saw the information, that
didn't matter so much.
But if this other
single male peer
was likely or possibly going
to see that information,
then these effects
would show up.
So that's overall showing
that, essentially,
what's perceived to
be undesirable traits,
such as ambition,
if that is perceived
to be damaging on the marriage
market, that can then, in turn,
reduce ambition and
then contributes
to the gender gap overall.
OK, let me tell you
now about a final paper
on saying no and on demand and
supply for different tasks.
This is a very nice paper
by Vesterlund et. al.
And it asks the question whether
women say no often enough.
And so that's motivated
by the observation
that female faculty member
spend fewer hours in research
and more hours on
university survey committees
than male faculty.
They are also more
likely to have positions
on university-wide committees.
They advise more
undergrad students
and participate more in
departments and college level
committees than male faculty.
More generally,
in mid-level jobs,
men more than women
evaluate the individual task
assignments as challenging.
And this is partially
attributed to differential task
assignments by supervisors.
So if you sort of see
these differences,
you might ask the
question, why do women
decide to spend or spends
their work time differently?
And there's two types
of dimensions here.
One is demand and one is supply.
So demand is
essentially the question
whether sex differences
in the types of tasks
that women and men are asked to
do at work is that [INAUDIBLE]
essentially what
they're being asked.
And are women more
likely than men
to be asked to do what's called
non-promotable tasks, tasks
that are not really
helpful for their career,
for getting promotions.
And then you might ask
why that's the case.
Supply is are there
sex differences
in the willingness to agree to
perform non-promotable tasks
when asked?
[INAUDIBLE] conditional
on being asked,
were women more
likely to say yes.
And, again, are women more
likely to demand to say yes
to non-promotable tasks.
Now why do we care?
Well, there's an individual
decision-making perspective,
which is that people might
make suboptimal decisions how
to allocate their work--
time at work.
And understanding these
underlying reasons
and [INAUDIBLE] understand
these underlying reasons,
which will lead them potentially
to some interventions
to improve decision-making
for certain individuals, which
have a lot of what
behavioral economics is.
But there's also managerial
and social planner perspectives
that organizations may not
be using their resources most
effectively.
And if you sort of
reallocated some of the tasks,
that would increase
output overall.
And then finally, there is
a public policy perspective.
Well, if these sex differences
in the allocation of time
explain vertical sex
segregation, essentially women
not being promoted
enough, then it
would help us sort of
improve gender equity overall
and perhaps also try to
reduce the gender gap.
Now what are these promotable
and non-promotable tasks
in the [INAUDIBLE] academics?
A promotable task is a
task that's doing research.
That's essentially what people
are evaluated on eventually,
but also any other task,
essentially, that's
seen where other
people will reward you
for it when you do it.
And non-promotable tasks
are essentially tasks
that often [INAUDIBLE],, many
people could do the task
and everybody wants
the task to be done,
yet everybody prefers
somebody else to do it.
An example would be an ethics
committee of the university.
Surely, we should have one.
But surely, sitting
on the committee
will not help
people get promoted
or get tenure when
it comes to research.
Now the authors had to do
a field study of faculty
at a large public university.
And they sent,
essentially, emails
from the chair of the faculty
senate asking them to volunteer
to join one of several
university-wide faculty senate
committees.
And the clear
answer in this study
is that women are much more
likely to volunteer when asked.
Now, that is an
interesting fact.
But it doesn't necessarily
let us disentangle the demand
and supply explanation that
I showed you previously.
So in addition
then, the authors do
a lot of experiments
in which they
do what's called the
threshold public good scheme.
And this is sort of very much
trying to mirror or resemble
the reality.
In this game, a small
group that needs
to find a volunteer for a task.
And participants are anonymously
matched into groups of three.
They're randomly every
match for each of 10 rounds.
The game is set up
such that everyone
prefers that the task
be undertaken by someone
other than themselves.
People get two minutes to
decide whether to invest.
And so the task is essentially
you have to click a button.
And then you invest the money.
Only one person can invest.
And the round ends
when somebody invests.
If no one invests, group
members all earn $1.
If a person invests,
that person earns
$1.25 and the remaining
group members earn $2.
The clock ticks down
until one person invests
or no investment is
made in two minutes.
So the game is
essentially set up
in a way such that everybody
wants that somebody--
and it's clear that
somebody should invest.
But nobody wants to invest
because if you invest, you
only $1.25.
But if you don't invest or
somebody else invests and you
don't invest, you get $2.
Now in this game, women
are significantly more
likely to invest.
We can essentially see the
probability of investing here
on the left side by round.
And the red line, which is
the upper line, the woman
line, the female line
is way, way higher
compared to the male line.
So there's much
higher probability
of investing in this game.
Now why are women
more likely to invest?
Is it the case
that women believe
that their cooperation is
necessary for an optimal group
decision, but men believe
that their cooperation isn't
required.
So it could be that women
think that, well, somebody--
if I don't do it,
nobody else does it.
And then men essentially think,
well, somebody else can do it,
in particular, women could do
it if they're in the group.
So then the authors do the
same experiment again using
single sex sessions where
essentially all three
people in the session are female
or all people in the session
are male.
And then what they
find is essentially,
interestingly, these differences
in gender now go away entirely.
There's no gender differences
in same sex sessions anymore.
So just to summarize,
so experiment one,
when there's a
mixed gender, women
are more likely to invest.
And experiment
two, women and men
are equally likely to invest.
Now, one question you
might ask is, well,
is it the case that
really, isn't this really
about beliefs?
So it could be that
there's no, in fact,
no differences in the
preferences for investing.
So it's not like women are
necessarily nicer than men.
But, rather, there are
differences in beliefs
that the women will invest.
in particular, if there's
a woman in the group,
everybody else will think, oh,
the woman is going to invest.
And the woman might think like,
well, if others don't invest
or others will not
invest, and she
might believe that,
she might have to
or think that she needs to
do that herself, otherwise
everybody will end up
with $1 and less money.
So now there's a
third experiment here
where people are ask
to essentially pick
whom they would like to ask.
And so there's four
people per group.
And three people can invest.
And the incentives
are [INAUDIBLE]..
These are like-- they're
called the green players.
And one person is
unable to invest,
but asks one of the
three to invest.
Importantly, the requests
are not even binding.
That's the red player.
The red player, essentially,
once the [INAUDIBLE] happens,
you incentivize
that that happens.
So this is kind of
what this looks like.
You would get like three
different players here.
And you can essentially decide
who you would like to trust.
And it's set up, of course,
that you can see the gender.
Some are male and
some are female.
Now women are way more
likely to be asked.
This is the total
times asked to invest
for male and female players.
This is the relative frequency.
And essentially, you can
see their distribution here
is way shifted to the right
for women compared to men.
Now is it better to ask a woman?
Well, absent a request, the
investment rate actually
does not differ by gender.
But when asked to invest, women
are more likely to comply.
So when the woman is asked
to invest, 76% of women
invest compared to
14% when not asked.
In contrast, men are also more
likely to invest when asked,
but it's only 51$ compared
to 14% when not asked.
So the marginal increase of
being asked is higher for women
than for men.
So if you're thinking about,
like whom should we ask?
Well, you kind of
want to ask a woman
because a woman is more likely
to comply with your request.
And so now if
women-- since women
are more likely to be expected
to say yes, they also ask more.
So in that sort of sense, you
know, the gender differences
get amplified by increased
demand for women to contribute.
Well, particularly, if there's
a man and a woman where
both can think about like
one of them could do it,
the man will think, well,
the woman will do it anyway.
The woman will think, well,
the man is not going to do it.
And he's going to think
that I will do it anyway.
And so then the woman
ends up doing it more.
In addition, when there's an
opportunity to ask somebody,
but asking is kind of
costly and you just
want to find somebody
who will do it.
But who will you ask?
You ask the woman.
Because she's more likely to
comply, more likely to say yes.
Let me sort of summarize
what we discussed.
So first is large gender,
wage, and earnings gaps.
They have been reduced due
to technological advances
and other improvements
over time.
But there are still persistent
gender differences in the US
and many other countries.
Bias beliefs and
identity concerns
play a major role in
explaining these differences.
In addition, there's
some feedback mechanisms
between the demand and supply
of non-promotable tasks
that could be, potentially
quite important.
Of course, I showed you
only a lab experiment.
but these could be
really important
in real-world situations.
So not only is it
that what matters
is what women decide to
do, but also what they're
asked to do by others,
in part as a response
to their propensity to say
yes or no to certain tasks.
Better understanding
these issues
can help us mitigate
the gender gap.
And we can sort of
then, by understanding
these issues better
and particular beliefs,
you might be able to improve
or correct biased beliefs
and, therefore, close
the gender gap potential.
What's next in the next
few lectures, lecture 19,
we'll talk about frames,
defaults, nudges,
and mental accounting.
Please read Madrian
and Shea 2001.
And lecture 20, we'll
look about-- talk
about malleability and
inaccessability of preferences.
Please read Ariely
2003 for that.
That was all I have to say.
Thank you so much.